c'est assez terrifiant ce que nous essayons
de faire, recréer cet
atterrissage en catastrophe héroïque qui traverse ce
vol aérien turbulent, les gens tournent et
retournent, c'est assez chaotique et amusant en
fait, je suis pilote et j'adore les
avions et ce qui est
intéressant  s'ils jouent un
incident, c'est que nous pouvons tous nous y identifier
parce que nous vivons nos vies dans des avions
et quand quelque chose ne va pas dans un
avion, c'est très dramatique et cela se
prête à un grand cinéma tout ce qui concerne
les principales séquences de vol est
scénarisé, ils sont tous  fait également dans
l'ordinateur en tant qu'animatique, ce que le
précédent a fait, c'est que cela nous a donné une idée de
quels sont les plans que Bob veut et
ensuite nous pourrions planifier et mesurer et
vraiment tout aligner afin que
nous sachions exactement ce que nous devons faire sur
le jour de cette année boum comme ça maintenant
c'est le coup que nous voulons gamin tombe boum
c'est bien maintenant l'avion fait demi-
tour et il s'arrête à 90 degrés et
continue d'aller arrêter pew pew pew pew continue
g donc c'est plutôt bien si tu l'as
presque eu donc là
on adore le bord gauche ça risque de rouler